welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity all throughout the Russia
collusion investigation the media has
done a great disservice to you the
American people using their platform
they're powerful platforms just to
attack the president they didn't dig for
the truth here with reaction former
White House press secretary Sean Spicer
yeah look I don't know how you did that
job
I don't know how Sara Sanders does the
job I would not be able to do that job
it would be entertaining for about a day
and it wouldn't end well but in a
serious note when you have Russian
collusion and Hillary paying for a
Russian dossier to lie to the American
people it's totally unverified then it's
used for a FISA warrant the bulk of that
information unverified and you have the
whole 2009 issue of Putin operatives in
the United States committing crimes
trying to get into the Iranian market we
ignore it even though we have an
informant and let that happen how is it
possible that the that the the press
only cares about Trump Russia and
nothing else Russia yeah well that's
because that's what they've been doing
forever if it's against a Republican or
conservative they they go full-bore on
it they'll find any narrative or thread
and tag on it if it's staring them right
in the face and sent a Democrat or it's
a Clinton they'll walk away from it
Peter Schweitzer gets that you have on
quite often wrote an entire book on it I
mean it's all laid out there all the
money all of the actions all the people
involved and it's sort of like you know
it made for a great interview once and
then everyone moved on from it but if
we're gonna talk about Russia and
collusion and in our action and money
and all that I think that there's a
roadmap for what the Clintons had did
that it's interesting just because she
lost the election doesn't mean that the
crimes or potential crimes should be
ignored yeah well I mean that that's the
whole point here is it really did they
really care about the truth or is it
that they only care about the narrative
that hurts the president and you know I
watched this dog-and-pony show every day
and you did it and then Sarah is doing
it every day I don't even know what the
purpose of it is at some points because
Sarah can give a statement and says okay
on something
keep going no it's it's because look I
said this over and over again both
during my time there and then since then
that the the briefing needs to serve a
purpose which is that the member my own
public of of actions or policy or
personnel decisions that occurred and in
lieu of when the president could speak
the president who got there and answer
their questions if you look at the
questions that get asked they asked the
same question over and over again and
it's because despite the fact that they
caught the answer they want to get their
little clip on television or to be able
to show it to their to their audience
it's not about getting information
anymore it's not about informing a
public it's about making YouTube stars
out of all of these folks that come in
day in and day out and I think one of
the things that's also important Shana
and this is what what you're getting at
is that it's not just what they cover
it's what they don't cover and and I
also would just say one quick thing
because we talked a lot about the
president but I think that joy Behar's
attack on the vice president's
Christianity and faith is just
despicable during this holy season of
Lent but I think what's even more
despicable is the fact that no one in
the media found it deplorable that she
went and did that in fact it was a vice
president hood who that had to respond
himself and defend himself instead of
having any other member Brooks or Jake
joy behar and say that was a little over
the line it was a lot over the line and
that's the point and you know I just
know that if a conservative says one
thing one word one sentence one phrase
you know the reaction is like oh you
know the outrage there's no revising and
extending remarks or even apologizing if
you were wrong and misstate something
well yeah I mean look I spent six years
at the RNC and with little Tommy yet
like West Jefferson middle school was
running for treasurer said something in
a offensive the RNC would get called
about what our comment was when the left
of the media stepped well over the line
the answer is well that's not what they
meant do you see that the media is
complicit do you after all that time you
spent as press secretary you don't have
to answer if you don't walk are they
complicit are they do you see them
totally in the tank for one side as I do
I think most I don't like to loop
everybody in on the same
broad-brush because there are some good
folks there that really try to pursue
journalism and the truth you know but I
think there are there are some that I
will enumerate in my book that are
coming out and I think that that's what
they should be praised but there are
folks just mentioned who's more
interested in getting clips and clicks
and becoming a star but what was the
last time the Jim Acosta broke any news
his it his entire career is made out of
the exchanges and the yelling that he
has and the level of obnoxious that he
reaches to as opposed to the news that
he breaks and the information that he
shares all right Sean Spicer thank you
we appreciate it